maxence à 18 ans il est apprenti
pâtissier et il a des mains en or et
pour faire fructifier ce trésor il
bénéficie des précieux conseils de cyril
son patron tu vas commencer le montage
des dom valentine donc à vous unir à
moitié remplie je suis après tu intègres
etats-unis 3-1 maxence a choisi la voie
de l'apprentissage pour exercer son
métier
ce système qui permet d'acquérir une
véritable expérience professionnelle
auprès d'un patron il retourne à l'école
une fois par semaine pour la théorie
mais pour la pratique rien de mieux que
le terrain cela met une meilleure façon
de découvrir un métier la prendre c'est
en faisant tous les jours plutôt qu'être
dans un lycée ou une semaine de pratique
un jour de pratique par semaine donc en
étant tous les jours on voit vraiment le
quotidien d'un métier c'est là pour la
prend au mieux je pense
cyril son patron ne ménage pas son temps
pour transmettre son savoir faire à son
apprenti cela demande de
l'investissement des deux côtés mais les
échanges sont riches bien défendre ce
qu'il apprend à l'école ils m'expliquent
ce qu'ils ont appris la manière de le
faire
et puis il voit aussi comment on
travaille ici donc ça va permettre de
comparer et puis d'échanger des idées
justement sur la manière de travailler
maxence à réaliser tout son cursus en
apprentissage et une filière qui
pourrait intéresser ces jeunes du
collège victor hugo à l'uni certains
souhaitent s'orienter dans le domaine
des fleurs de l'esthétique ou du vin
n'apprendrait avec un patron face à
apprendre et ce coffret plus tard donc
ce bus nadège donne des informations sur
le cursus d'un apprenti et d'après les
chiffres beaucoup trouveraient taux
d'emploi la sortie comme l'apprentissage
on apprend directement le métier sur le
terrain quand on sort diplômé de
l'apprentissage
on a huit apprentis sur 10 quand même
qui dans les deux trois mois trouvent un
emploi derrière en bourgogne franche
comté en compte près de onze mille six
cent cinquante apprentis pour 250
formations diverses et variées